and if you're looking for mortgage and
real estate consulting thanks to smg
media group the sponsors of this next
segment we have an expert for you with a
very unique approach take a look
we're so excited to have you here
because one you're from reno
yep you're from reno born and raised so
you're familiar with the state of nevada
and two
your offices your corporate offices are
right here in las vegas so you're no
stranger to our city either i've been
living in the bay area for
about 17 years on and off and i'm just
trying to dig it up right now i still
have my nevada driver's license oh we
love it i'm always i'm always here
you can't let us go no i love it it'll
always be my home i love that okay well
you are a mortgage expert you know what
you're doing you've been doing this for
years um you know let's talk about your
journey and just how you got into the
industry in the first place so i was
living in reno in college my last year
of school in a fraternity house and i
had a few of my fraternity brothers that
had either graduated or had stopped
going to school that moved back home to
vegas
and this was back in 2001 and they were
doing really well doing mortgages long
story short they needed help in reno so
i started running paperwork back when
fax machines were still a thing you know
i worked through the market crash and
was a part of it in the sense that you
know i was affected back in 00809 during
the great recession
i had a lot of real estate holdings and
you know i had to do short sales like a
lot of people did and it messed up
people's credit of course and so my kind
of the biggest
piece of fulfillment that i get from the
industry has been over this this last
decade helping people in what are called
re-entry buyers people that were in the
market that had the exit either because
they lost their home or they had to do a
short sale and then be able to re-enter
the market after we helped them either
fix their credit or they fixed it on
their own can you just break it down the
services that you guys provide all we
deal with our mortgage products so if
you are a renter or you're a current
homeowner and you've got a you've got a
mortgage that you've been sitting on you
have this debt and i like to think of us
as debt managers you have wealth
managers and then you have debt managers
we work with you and basically helping
you
assess your finances and look at the
entire big picture how this is going to
impact you on a wealth level a tax level
a savings level and see if it is the
right time for you because it may not be
but if you're looking to buy that's the
type of interaction we have with you and
then help guide you through the process
and then we stay connected to you well
beyond closing most people assume that a
mortgage is just a quick one-off
transaction which is kind of what the
you know the internet has created a
little bit with e-lenders and people
just going online and doing something
but if you're gonna borrow hundreds of
thousands of dollars if not millions of
dollars i would think you'd want some
advisement and you know to actually do
with a partner as opposed to just doing
blindly on your own so that's you know a
little bit about our process it's very
virtual and electronics easy uh and uh
not like how it was many years ago when
i got into the industry
but it's very consumer-centric and so
it's educational it's guiding and
ultimately impactful you guys you're in
san francisco your
corporate home is here in las vegas so
how are you guys getting more business
here how are you taking care of our
community because this is now such a
virtual
and internet based world i don't have to
be in las vegas physically to be able to
serve that market there's a lot of
content creation that i do that i put
out on social media via instagram
facebook and linkedin so i reach a lot
of my audience that is southern
nevada-based and we've been able to help
uh and just help people break through
that market
thank you to smg media group for
sponsoring that segment for more
information just head to
arjundingra.com we'll be right back
right here on las vegas now